let's talk a little bit about alex jones
i so you've gotten a chance to talk to
him
while you're on the joe rogan experience
i've been on alex's show
i've talked i've had alex on my show
i've talked to
alex for three hours in front of i guess
it was maybe like 15 million people
right on joe's show it was a really
wild conversation i think it was one of
the coolest moments in broadcasting
that i clearly that i've ever been a
part of but i think it goes in the
lexicon of like
these are big podcasts like i think it's
one of the biggest podcasts a week
before the election
alex jones i'm really grateful that joe
gave me the opportunity to be there
and i it was just an amazing
conversation to watch what was the
shirt you award uh it was a fun joke
that no one in tech got because we all
know how funny they are
uh but the tech writers which is mainly
do not agree with these
mainly blue haired people whose you know
goal in life is to find
things to give them orgasms with you
know without to dye your hair blue it's
your choice yeah i respect it and but
is it your choice but at the end of the
day it's like you know all the tech
writers like a lot of people just
and i'm not i'm just maligning tech
unfairly but a lot of people in that
sense of humor were like he's
advocating for a human trafficker i'm
like it's clearly a joke because we're
coming off the believe all women
yes we're coming off that and it's very
funny to just say friedrichs lane hey
man believable women like
it's just our politics and our and our
public sphere is so schizophrenic right
now
that when you point that out people are
going to be angry with you but that was
a fun shirt to wear
you